so again lots of setups like this one
for blood donation drives were canceled
throughout the pandemic and even this
summer
as people drive or have uh vacations and
they're not home as often and with the
pandemic schools were out so drives
weren't just happening
all about town like they used to so
there is a critical need so
we are joined here by brittany estrella
from
the by talent so tell us there is a
critical need
now that you are having more blood
drives can people who have gotten
coveted or gotten their coveted vaccine
can they give blood
all who have been vaccinated can donate
blood without a different time and we
ask anyone in our community who is
healthy and feeling well
if they can donate at this time since
there is a national critical blood
shortage that we are experiencing not
only in las vegas but nationwide
wow and so i understand you know blood
is important it has a very short shelf
life it has to be used immediately they
can't store it for months on end
is there a type that you're looking for
that really helps the most people
possible
during the blood shortage we are looking
for all blood types right now but
specifically there is a severe shortage
of type
o blood type o is used in a trauma
situation
and it's a universal blood type as well
so we are specifically asking those in
our community who are type o
to donate this weekend but all blood
types are needed during the shortage
and this helps so many people from
people who are in car crashes
new mothers transfusions sickle cell
people with sickle cell
and so many people are going to benefit
from somebody donating an hour out of
their time this weekend so give us the
details
this blood drive happening the third and
the fourth and kind of an incentive for
to get folks to come out that's right
all donors will receive a complimentary
admission to wet n wild
and a vitale t-shirt redeemable via
email
and you can make an appointment at
vitalin.org or call 877
25 vital to donate all right so again
this weekend while you make those plans
to cook
out before you start the cookout why
don't you come down
again the third and fourth and donate
and help save a life
this weekend gonna send it back to you
guys in the studio